il peut être à l'être gardien tu voies
biliaires thani la passe est encore bon
pour deux championnats fallait qu'ils se
réconcilient leurs excès il y en a trois
choses en place
mes cheveux et cortal france que c'est
bien si si ce sont vraiment les
conseiller dans la vie ça de pandémie se
tasser mais puis devoir se sacrifier
alors grâce à une campagne de publicité
faut quand même le dire c'est grâce à
une campagne de publicité d'hubert it
je sais pas qui a eu l'idée soit chez
hubert il on va lui poser la question au
principal intéressé mais de réconcilier
mario tremblay et patrick roy c'est un
bon coup mario très vite avec nous
monsieur tremblay bonsoir bonsoir
patrice evra bien ça va très bien et
vous c'est une belle journée pour vous
wéo effectivement le réseau patrice une
très belle journée je pense que c'est
une campagne publicitaire qui a fait
vraiment parler les gens puis comme les
commentaires qu'on attend du temps
touche parce que c'est après tant
d'années l'oeil était un temps d'avoir
deux se trouvaient pas témoin je pense
que les québécois semblent être très
content aussi de mettre fin à cette
histoire locale 25,495 alors je pense
que lorsque monsieur monsieur simorre ce
nom du groupe bp avait aucun intérêt
avec patrick bon lorsqu'on m'a appelé
honnêtement j'étais un peu sceptique
genre ouais vous voulez vous qu'on fasse
une petite distance entre patrick et moi
qu'est ce que l'agent racontez moi
comment comment ça c'est fait la réunion
la baisse et la réunion confirme ce
serait par téléphone bp tente intérêt
parce que lui été approché par ribéry
pour pour connecter patrick et moi
sommes dans le même commercial alors
quand quand me chercher nos applis il ya
du québec avec justesse alors yannick
m'appelle et italyachts
tagetik ou de faire un commercial
patrick roy j pardon c'est quoi ce soit
sérieux
maintenant il est atteint il dit mais
chercher nos a parlé avec patrick haouat
ouais bah ce moment là je dis bon et si
patrick est prêt bon je suis je prête à
le faire c'est et puis quand on parlait
chaunac
et puis quand on a vu le script it shows
avec juste un peu sarcastique mais c'est
vraiment bien fait patrice pour dit on
est vraiment content de s'être trouvés
vous avez vu ces images là un milliard
de fois on voit des remords et le 2
décembre 95 ouais ouais même tête une
dernière françois une des dernières
photos patrick roy et se fait compter
début 1-2-3 jusqu'à 9 vous on vous voit
derrière le bas vous avez remplacé cette
année là j'arrive avec le canadien et là
il ya on a décrit sa de mille manières
mais comme un combat de coqs run pas
content de lui vous est ce que vous vous
êtes expliqué avant la publicité sur
vous lui avez vous dit pourquoi je t'ai
pas à lever des filets à ce que lui vous
a parlé ou êtes même plus là dessus je
pense qu'on est au lit puis là dessus
mais je pense que patrick l'a quand même
très bien expliqué patrice cartier a
mentionné quand même qu'un mario ou
viendra me dire tu es résument à enlever
effectivement je réduis de l'enlever
après sec mais je voulais attendre un
peu plus parce que c'est un patrick
heure ou 1 avec son statut mais je leur
ai dit de l'enlever après sexy but
malheureusement ce pas arrivé pour les
patines de son côté dit bon ben moi
aussi on a dit que deux médailles celle
de goûter à l'or lui dit quote je ne
pouvais pas d'affaires à main levée bref
j'arrête j'avais beau ben là c'est mon
biscuits l'ofppt aller voir mario
l'admets mais ça passe ici et c est à ce
point c'est un cap je pense que
l'important dans tout ça c2c la
réconciliation à patrick et moi et
kotone mambo même type de golf en
floride
non ces quatre auteurs hausse par la
poste c'est un peu malaise parce qu'on
ait les mêmes usages
on connaît les mêmes j'avais pour jouer
au golf le maire d'assat votre chose du
passé donc vous vous c'est vrai vous
étiez recroiser mais jamais y avait eu
une discussion franche et même une
discussion entre vous deux non il ya
déjà on s'est croisé on s'est dit
bonjour par contre on n'est quand même
pas des sauvages
on s'est dit bonjour mais jamais l'or
pur comme c'est le cas présentement
cadeaux terrible tournée commerciale à
québec
la première chaussure patrick made easy
scénario dans le fond je t'aime je
t'aime je t'aime beaucoup aurait dit moi
aussi parce que je t'aime beaucoup
mathieu parce que les gens ont tendance
à oublier patrice que avant ça arrive
cette histoire-là cap at il taclé cannes
bien moi je tombais terrain et
l'entraîneur l'avait placé avec moi
comme co chambreur alors on a eu des
bons moments ensemble complet bien avant
que ça arrive cette histoire là quand
serge savard est en poste il y avait eu
des rumeurs justement que patrice
changer et moi je pense honnêtement que
les dix années où patrick ont été de
votre film du canadien
et dieu sait qu'elles sont un travail
vraiment extraordinaire pense que la
pression commençait à gurgy
tranquillement mais c'est ça peut-être
que fait sauter des plantes patrick soi
même et dans le fond je passais richard
bolduc a même correct on n'a pas changé
d'un club de dernière position
- les charges et l'avalanche du colorado
j'ai eu la chance de gagner deux coupes
stanley oui si vous deux vous êtes
arrivé à vous réconcilier d'abord petite
question avant c'est une vraie vraie
réconciliation c'est juste pour la barre
haut patronage google france a beau
mirage laval en produit que trois
parties s'assoient rds à des châtels
maccabi on ne joue au golf qui est où on
a eu du fun on a changé dans ok je me
suis informé des remparts de québec qui
a des mauvais du québec
ok alors appuyé lui en bon terreau alors
sérieuse balle pour ceux qui parce qu'on
fasse de la publicité
il ya l'amitié l'argent ce que vous
n'avez pas dû recevoir 4,5 sous pour
faire seul zoo s'était pas trompé
attaquons cacher ma gêne c'est pop et
[Rires]
pédagogue l'année
donc je n'ai pas fait ça pour la rebelle
oui ça aide à accepter mais c'est une
vraie réconciliation oui avec l'autre
puisqu'on attend parce que c'est dans le
fond vous resterez spectale puis au lac
c'est déjà ça fait le reste robert mario
tremblay et du béret dont hubert reeves
ça va aider justement des restaurateurs
dans cette période de coville qui en ont
vraiment arraché alors je pense que ça
va être bon un peu pour les la publicité
puis ça va permettre justement a eu à
hubert est justement de d'avoir une
bonne percée au québec comme aujourd'hui
c'est la journée où les gens revoient
leur monde en trois ans sur les terres
aspect une journée de déconfinement il
ya quelque chose de symbolique aussi si
vous deux vous avez vous êtes des
caractères forts cet orgueilleux
si vous de vous arriver à faire la paix
ça veut dire qu'on peut faire ce dont on
vit aussi ça peut arriver de rappeler
quelqu'un à qui on n'a pas parlé depuis
20 ans patrice très bon point et apporte
l'appui patrick est bon de temps lui
aussi et puis on saisit garde
en faisant ça aussi ça va montrer aux
gens que avec la coved ça il ya eu
beaucoup de problèmes dans des familles
ou des discussions qui ont pas eu lieu
ou d'humoristes à l'est pas alors je
pense que là dedans au québec on veut
donner l'exemple
patrick et moi en se réconciliant les
gones ont été bons mais si tremblay qui
revoit le fond après après 25 années
nous aussi on peut le faire je pense que
si on peut donner si on peut allumer les
gens de ce côté là je pense que patrick
et moi travail parce que vous avez
divisé le québec y avait des pros moi
j'avais des programmes les tcl c'est sûr
mais là le chaleureux mais une
réunification le rythme et surtout être
patrice depuis deux jours c'était
incroyable
en fait je voulais je te dirais que
c'est pas mal plus positives que
négatives
on va écouter un petit extrait de
patrick roy ses interviewés par dave
morissette tva sports oui très bonne
entrevue dire des mauriciens pendant 28
minutes pas trop on va être très petit
bout et on revient on va écouter sans ça
et moi si je suis vraiment content de ce
rapprochement nous on se croise et le
daim dans la dernière année quelques
occasions à enfler la queen's on sait
lui et ses termes et avec son ami commun
plus un malaise puis quand même un bon
ok parfait merci marco l'entendent mais
moi aussi je le faut je me regarde dans
le miroir pour enlever brown à prat
apple
chacun fait des erreurs c'est ce qu'ils
disent est ce que vous avez des talents
puis on parle c'est une belle bâtisse
une médaille ça de bon j'ai mon côté ok
c'est là qu'est ce qu avec les dom
avant de vous laisser aller pour pour le
canadien pas ça c'est bon c'est bon
comme relations publiques de deux
joueurs mythiques là d'un gros joie
qu'ils se réconcilient mélasse sur la
glace est-ce que ça va pas si vous
croyez j'espère j'espère juste respect
de l'ofsp a fini j'espère que le
canadien va continuer patrice de la même
façon qu'ils ont joué dans le match
numéro cinq à toronto parce que le
problème contre le canadien cette saison
on sait jamais quelle krups va sortir
c'est une crise sociale dans le numéro 5
ou dans le match numéro 4 ici ici au
centre bell demain soir je suis d'autant
plus patrice va y avoir deux mille cinq
cents personnes dansant d'elle alors je
pense que des joueurs du canadien n'ont
pas d'autre choix que de sortir gonflé à
bloc pour essayer d'avoir un asthme
numéro 7 à toronto
vous savez vous arrêter dans
l'organisation mario tremblay 2500
billets est ce qu'on arrête pas de vue
les donner à des employés de la santé
parce que là c'est déjà qu'ils ont
beaucoup de moyens
il ya des pères qui s'en vont à douze
mille piastres j'ai regardé la dernière
heure ces fossiles fou raide le vote
comme un moment passé d'al nasr
ci-dessus tu la mets ton point de vue
très bon on est réputé mais ça aussi à
ta raison aux jeunes à s'arrêter ou à
des gens qui sont moins dans le mouillé
pour qui veut que je mette au sein belle
mes gars c'est leur décision a eu mario
tremblay ça m'a fait plaisir de vous
parler merci de nous avoir parlé ce soir
et bonne fin de journée puis bon match
demain puis on suit la suite merci merci
patrice bon week-end au revoir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit
oh
[Musique]